let's bring in kaylee mcinnady white
house press secretary good morning to
you kaylee
good morning ainslie good morning what
was your reaction uh yesterday
to joe biden going after president trump
uh on
the economy actually yeah let's play it
and then you can get your react we'll
get your reaction on the other side
president trump keeps talking about how
great this economy is
how great the stock market is but hadn't
been so great for the rest of us
millions of people out of work evictions
on the rise
20 million people worrying about whether
they're going to lose their home what in
god's name else can this guy do
let's look at one simple fact this
president is on track to be the only
president
in modern history to end up
with fewer jobs at the end of his term
than
existed in america when he began his
term
kaylee is that fair we just went through
or we are in the middle of a pandemic
yeah the one thing for joe he wants to
talk about simple facts i have a few
simple facts for him let's
start with the fact that obama biden
oversaw the slowest economic recovery
since world war ii he had his bite at
the apple
that's what they delivered compare that
to president trump fastest economic
recovery in modern history
the cbo told us that we were supposed to
have double-digit unemployment until the
end of the year
uh we are in single digits right now
record number of jobs created
outpacing the rest of the world on terms
of an economic recovery
so we're on track with the jobs
president but the pathetic record of
obama biden
stands very clear and those are simple
facts all right the other thing that
everyone's talking about
was excited about but it seems to be
politicized as the race to get a vaccine
the president said
december i'm hoping for uh maybe earlier
in november
uh joe biden says the president's got a
credibility issue let's listen
full transparency of the vaccine one of
the problems is
the way he's playing with policy is he
said so many things that aren't true
i'm worried if we do have a really good
vaccine people are going to be reluctant
to take it
and so he's undermining public
confidence but pray god we have it if i
could get a vaccine tomorrow i'd do it
if it cost me the election i do it we
need a vaccine
we need it now let's quickly be together
we have to listen to the scientists
was the president going to come up with
a vaccine himself
or is he going to depend on the
scientists he's going to depend on the
scientists which is what he's done every
single step
of the way what uc democrats doing is
very very dangerous they are literally
playing politics
with people's lives here by sowing doubt
about a vaccine
we have renowned experts over at
operation warp speed that are working on
this president trump
has tore through bureaucratic
bureaucratic barriers so we can get a
safe
effective and timely vaccine and once
again compare that to obama biden where
they promised a vaccine
they vastly underperformed i mean you
have biden's advisor
back in the the obama biden day saying
it's a pure miracle
fortuity that swine flu wasn't a mass
casualty event of our time
you know kayla last time you were with
us we asked you about that music you
would think that you would be able to
figure out where it's coming from
that's right apparently it's some sort
of protest but what's funny is i don't
think the viewers can hear the music so
they think that we're just hearing this
music in our no we can hear them
hey um you know clearly the president as
he goes to jupiter florida today
and then to north carolina as well he's
going to be talking about the
environment today
down in florida where people are very
concerned about the red tide and blue
algae
but he's also going to be talking about
the chaos in the streets and the economy
now one of the things that hogan gidley
put out a statement yesterday talking
about the differences between the
president
and joe biden and one of the things he
said was the joe biden
is promising to raise taxes on more than
80 percent of taxpayers
by 4 trillion dollars that's a lot of
money
on social media you see people talking
about he's going to double our taxes and
things like that
where are you getting that figure he's
going to raise
uh 4 trillion on 80 percent of the
people
yeah well just one simple proposal look
at the payroll tax on capitol hill you
have a democrat there proposing to roll
back the president's
uh payroll tax forgiveness this is a
huge
tax that forgives that that benefits
mostly middle and low-income workers
i mean at the same time we're not
touching social security because the
money
is coming out of the general fund to pay
for this just simply the payroll tax
democrats will pull that back
and also the trump tax cuts but doesn't
a majority of the four trillion dollars
come from people making more than four
hundred thousand dollars a year
now when you look at the trump tax cuts
what they've done is benefit
mostly low and middle income americans
as a percentage
i mean the payroll tax cuts in
particular that's for people
making under 100 000 it is a regressive
tax
and we know that low and middle income
workers the vast majority of their taxes
come from that payroll tax so that's
what this president has prioritized in
the midst of a pandemic
um and you'll have joe biden and others
rolling back those trump tax cuts and
not forgiving the payroll tax which
president trump has promised that he
would do
so kaley the senate is heading back to
work today what's the latest on uh
the the covid relief yeah right now
again it's nancy pelosi playing politics
she has been fundamentally unserious
every step of the way here they would
ask for a certain number of school
funding we would exceed that amount and
then they would reject it
she's saying she wants 2.5 trillion
dollars but won't say
what that money will go to democrats
want a bailout for blue states
and look at the priorities here when
this president put out eos to help stop
evictions
um into that payroll tax cut i mentioned
and other items what was nancy pelosi
doing
vacationing and going to a hair salon
when no one else in california or in her
area at least had the benefit of that
yeah well the rubber hits the road
evidently is money to states and who's
it going to go to
and where it's going to end up meanwhile
the other big story that's been
resonating over the last three days is
jeffrey goldberg's atlantic
magazine report that said that the
president called those who died in world
war one
uh suckers and some other disparaging
remarks and losers
uh and veterans in particular he says he
has anonymous sources of moral coming
forward
we did know john bolton told martha
mccallum last night is not a fan of the
president
that that didn't happen and he was there
zach fuentes an aide to general kelly
says it didn't happen and he was there
um
who else was there that you like to hear
from
well i've heard from enough people i've
heard in fact from 19
on the record sources who put their
names
on their testimony and those 19 sources
more than a dozen of which have first
hand accounts have dismissed this said
it is fundamentally untrue
you have a liberal activist publication
in the atlantic
proffering these absolute lies about
president trump
and again anonymous cowardly anonymous
sources
won't put their name on their
allegations but you have now almost 20
people
putting their names on this and saying
that this is fundamentally untrue and
this president loves our veterans i see
it each and every day
he deeply cares about our military and
this is democrats trying to wedge
uh veterans away from a president that
has done more for them than any
president in the history of our country
all right kaylee mcnaney